[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and these
are the new airpods pro
could you tell the difference
yeah right good because i i wouldn't
want you thinking i had like the old
airpods or something all right so
apple's quietly dropped the new airpods
on their site yesterday and i've been
using them for about a day now from when
this video is going live so these are
some first impressions and they're
honestly pretty nice now these cost
250 dollars like that's pretty high-end
so at this point they can't sound like
crap anymore they're actually competing
with some other really nice headphones
at this price or even nice earbuds at
this price so
what's so pro about these new airpods
pro
well i'll tell you everything that's new
first of all the new design so you can
see them here they're a little bit
smaller and they have a shorter stem and
they kind of look like that one pokemon
or maybe a hair dryer
or maybe even pingu
man the internet is fast to meme these
new apple products but i honestly don't
think they look that bad they're a
little less toothbrushy more reasonable
looking more compact
we've seen how weird these types of
headphones can get with stuff like the
microsoft surface buds i think this is
an improvement i actually wish they came
in more colors and that actually was one
of the rumors that there might be a
black pair
and as hard as they would be to find if
you lost them
i still would have liked to have seen
that but you still have glossy white now
again for your in-ear headphones but
they are now officially ipx4 rated for
water resistance so that's good for
you know it's sweat resistant basically
good for a light rain if you're wearing
them you want to go outside you
shouldn't have to worry ipx4 and there's
of course the rubber tips now so in the
unboxing you'll see they come with three
different size rubber tips total the
mediums are attached out the box and
they have a smaller pair and a bigger
pair and actually do a little apple
magic with that that i'll show you in a
second and they of course still have the
h1 chip so they'll pair by just being
near your iphone and opening the case
and then you get this little tutorial on
how to use these new airpods pro and
with this tutorial as you can see it
talks you through media controls reading
you your messages out loud with siri and
ios 13.2
and
noise cancellation and that's because
that's right airpods pro do have active
noise cancellation and this is a rumor
that i was sort of on the fence about if
they would do it or not they did it so
this isn't just the passive noise
isolation that comes with any pair of
earbuds that make a seal in your ear
this uses the microphones and the
earbuds themselves to do active
additional
noise cancellation in earbuds and this
is just my first impression so far but
the noise cancellation is pretty decent
i'd say it's about on par if you get a
good seal with the beats solo pro that
i've been testing which are on ear
headphones i mean they're honestly
better than i expected from any sort of
earbuds i don't use many noise canceling
earbuds not sure if i'd wear them on a
plane they're not that good but hey
maybe some testing will change my mind
in time for when i do the full review
the earbuds themselves as you've seen
have this larger black grille on the
sides and that's for air to pass through
so even when you're wearing them with
the in-ear seal you can still hear
sounds and you don't feel like you're
all clogged up when you normally wear
earbuds
because of that air pass-through so
that's pretty cool and you can still
hear sounds around you and that's thanks
to transparency mode so you can turn on
the noise cancellation a bunch of
different ways you can flip it on in the
quick settings in ios 13.2 with that
volume
or you can squeeze the stem which is now
pressure sensitive for about a second
and it'll activate noise cancellation or
you can even activate it from your watch
if you want to either way you'll hear a
chime and it kicks in
and it's this pretty good noise
cancellation without that vacuum feeling
thanks to the air pass-through there's
even built into ios this little thing
this is the magic i talked about called
the ear tip fit test and you can open it
and run through it it'll play a short
sound into your ear and use the
microphones inside airpods pro to
determine if you have a good fit or not
a good seal if you don't it'll tell you
either one or both of them you need to
adjust the size of the rubber tips you
have on for a better seal and then you
can get them right
i haven't seen that anywhere before and
it seems to work really well and again
this isn't the full review but as far as
sound quality they sound
fine you know these are new drivers and
with the noise cancellation on they
sound better and without the noise
cancellation they sound okay
you know i'm gonna give much more
detailed feedback for the full review
and i'll compare them to other earbuds
and things in the price range but for
now
not bad oh and of course you can't
forget last but not least the new case
uh the case itself is actually a little
bigger a little bit wider mostly than
the previous airpods case but nothing
too drastic it's almost like you turn
the old one sideways and stretch that a
little bit but it still has wireless
charging like gen 2 still very
pocketable and still gives you that
quick charging and 24 hours of total
battery life and it's also still
lightning not that i expected usb type c
for every apple pro product but yeah
still lightning but that is pretty much
everything that's new with the brand new
airpods pro why are they called the pro
i don't know it's just kind of like
everything that's high end is just
called pro now whether it's usbc or high
refresh rate or multiple colors or not
um i know for a fact there's no audio
engineers waiting to use airpods pro in
their studios but those are the new
features
and so far it seems like a pretty
complete package but i think in theory
this solves what my biggest problem was
with the previous airpods which is
they didn't sound great but they also
fell out of my ear instantly this is
about how much you'd stick in a normal
pair of air pods right
so that's like
five yards of running so in theory these
new ones solve that problem for me by
having this little rubber tip they're
not going to fall out of my ear as
easily and they're going to sound
better
and that's definitely good to see but
let me know are you into these are you
into this i mean this weird silent
announcement they did with airpods pro
they're on the site now they're
available today or tomorrow i believe
you can get them in stores october 30th
and
they look a little different but same
vibe same idea just more expensive and
some more features
the cancellation is actually pretty
impressive definitely stay tuned for the
full review for sound quality and all of
my thoughts and let me know if you have
any questions or comments down below
what you want to see in the full review
and subscribe to be among the first to
see it if you haven't already either way
until the next one thank you for
watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]